let's jump to this uh next story
actually and Luke I want to throw this
one to you if you want to want to talk
about this yeah I mean this is a little
bit more I mean this is the story I
don't even know where to begin there's a
lot of emotions here but so uh Vladimir
zielinski of Ukraine claimed Russian
missiles hit Poland and then immediately
started ramping up calling for for a
reciprocation calling for more Aid and
more military directly blaming Russia
before too much was known now you know
Fair Point this was AP reporting it
because the U.S official said so
for a world leader to then call for an
escalation of war and trying Jackson in
World War III is horrifying now we even
have NATO countries saying like yo this
dude's kind of losing it so maybe it
won't be a new world order maybe it will
be Ukraine sparking World War III our
foolishness NATO joining in the fight
getting into a war with Russia nukes get
fired but uh some people have pointed
something that interesting so some
missiles hit Poland right initially it
was reported that they were Russian
everybody losing their minds some people
said it was a false flag some people are
now saying it was a false flag done so
poorly that not even NATO could pretend
it was actually Russian missiles but if
it was Ukrainian missiles that struck
Poland then do we call do we do we
invoke Article Five against Ukraine I
thought that too yeah it's up to Poland
I guess Poland's like we declare war on
Ukraine good let's stop giving him money
at the very least yeah I mean it's this
is just such a crazy situation that
could have escalated so fast and thank
goodness it it didn't I mean I'm from
Poland I love my country I don't want to
see War it's already horrible that
there's war in Ukraine that so many
people have to suffer through this
nonsense and to have people try to
escalate this conflict trying to get
other countries involved in this
conflict trying to expand this proxy war
between the East and the West is
extremely Reckless it's extremely
dangerous there's an article that I just
tweeted on on my Twitter page uh from
the Independent talking about how
zielinski is certain that this blast in
Poland came from a Russian enemy
missiles again no one was certain no one
knew what was going on here uh but of
course the corporate media didn't wait
MSNBC was talking about retaliation
immediately I have an article here here
pulled up by the daily mail saying the
West plots their response against Russia
and again we don't know exactly what
happened here as right now the president
of the United States the president of
Poland the head of NATO are coming out
and saying it actually wasn't a Russian
missile it was most likely a missile
that was provided to Ukraine by the West
in order to act like a defense system
that could have accidentally or
purposefully depending what you believe
here could have been a potential false
thought I could have not been a flag
could have been a real legit accident
here but with zelinski's comments here
it really makes you wonder because they
were aggressive they were hyperbolic and
they're extremely dangerous not only to
the people of Ukraine but the people of
Poland the people of the world and this
situation is reckless and needs to stop
immediately we have this article from
The Daily Mail zelenski insists missile
that hit Poland was Russian despite NATO
U.S and even Polish president saying it
was a Ukrainian air defense misfire but
all agree Putin to blame for nearly
sparking World War III oh how about that
huh well yeah again Putin did start the
war and we have to understand here his
major calling card throughout all of
this is like it's him specific
specifically saying there's going to be
a new world order we want Russia to be a
part of this new world order so that's
one of his major stances that he's
always been making as he's been calling
out the West here but this proxy war is
again Reckless stupid dangerous and and
the corporate media organizations that
spread fake news automatically after
this didn't offer any retractions didn't
have any edit statements didn't have any
corrections on their articles the AP
literally just changed their article
from Russia attacks Poland to to just to
something else I'm I'm some icing here
I'm not exactly saying the exact titles
here but you get the drift of what I'm
trying to say here they were normally
spreading dangerous fake news that could
have started a global war and I disagree
they were knowingly doing it they were
when you don't know what happened you
can't automatically jump to conclusions
and state it as fact when the stakes are
as high as they are exactly yeah and
that's exactly what they did they say
automatically this is it we don't know
what happened here and you see how
thirsty these are these people are for a
global conflict which should be
prevented at all costs here another
thing to really consider here is the
fact that you know governments and
militaries make mistakes all the time
and it could just be a dumb Soldier it
could be an accident it could be a
miscalculation and boom we have World
War III this is why this conflict needs
to be de-escalated needs to be stopped
people need to come to the table sit
down and negotiate a peace deal
immediately now it it before it's too
late I agree I agree that
again the stakes really are so high with
all of this and it's become just sort of
passive like well something else
happened today you know it's just a
headline but meanwhile
literally the whole world is at stake
the the with nuclear war and it's and
it's right on our doorstep
um and again as I was saying before
about
about this trend towards destroying
everything why why aren't we trying
why aren't we investing 60 billion
dollars whatever it is in peacekeeping
efforts or trying to keep the peace and
just stopping all this whoever's dying
on on both sides it's just awful again
it's the energy that's being created
there is sadness and destruction and and
just awfulness that that projects out
into the world and and Beyond in a
different realm and it just it makes
everything sour and and and leads us
towards
I wish it were as easy as to just say
you know we shouldn't have War but the
challenge I guess is when you see some
of the things that we've seen with
um Isis for instance and they're not
stopping and they're expanding and the
caliphate was growing and growing and
growing at a certain point it's like you
can cross your fingers now for peace all
you want but dangerous people
start pushing and doing crazy stuff now
I'm not arguing the U.S should have
intervened in the Middle East in the
first place I think U.S intervention
caused the rise of Isis but I use this
as an example of what do you do when you
see a country expand like China's
expanding dramatically in the South
China Sea we can we we can sit back and
just be like you know let's just keep
the peace and hope nothing happens but
they keep expanding the same thing is
true and look here's the issue NATO is
doing the exact same thing so I'm not
saying that any good guys here but if
you're trying to be Noble and honorable
and just say I'm gonna do everything I
can to keep the peace but the person
across from you is just cheating lying
and stealing at a certain point it comes
to blows
um um I understand that war is certainly
a part of our existence in this space
and in this realm
but I do not believe in this instance
that war is
could have been averted or it should be
averted I don't understand why everybody
uh our Administration our country leans
into these sort of things the anti-war
effort where is every where is everybody
that was so upset about war when it was
happening in Iraq and Afghanistan and
everyone was like yeah the Russians are
bad kill them all yeah right after the
Crimea annexation is when it kicked back
up all this anti-russians well so so
I'll give you the gist I suppose and
this is coming from somebody with no
clearance so I have no idea but I do
know that the U.S wants control of
Ukraine Western forces NATO because
Russia controls a large percentage
percentage of natural gas flowing into
Europe which means that the economy of
Europe is staggered by Russia so the U.S
basically wants to take control of
Ukraine control the valves of natural
gas into Europe and then put the
pressure back on Russia Russia refuses
this war happens
so I suppose
um you can argue NATO should not have
been expanding the way it was and we'd
avoid war and high gas prices is better
than War I think that's a part of it but
I think but we wouldn't have high gas
prices we would have lower gas prices if
we had just uh better relations with
other countries and more free trade in
the market Russia was charging a lot and
so Western forces tried to build a
pipeline through Syria through turkey
into Europe to compete with Russia but
Syria wouldn't allow it surprise
surprise Syria destabilizes how
fortunate and like the point is it's not
just about the cost of the gas it's
about how much energy are we getting so
they say the EU was formed explicitly to
unify Europe against the growing threat
of China and they need gas not not so
much just cheap but they need more so
that they can expand their economy grow
and be able to compete with a growing
Chinese economy Russia was causing
problems that regard because Russia
tacitly works with China so the US was
like we're not going after China first
Russia is the weak Target and went after
them Donald Trump was right when he was
like China as the bigger threat and they
freak freak out because they're like
yeah but we want to go after Russia
first so look I don't like any of it I
don't think any of it's Justified I
think it's a bunch of paranoia and and I
understand the arguments people make
about the fear of a uni of a multi-polar
world where you could potentially get
World War III but this is what it boils
down to the liberal World Order people
do not want Russia and China to gain
enough power to compete with their new
world order their liberal World Order
because they fear world war three would
happen if that was the case so they'll
will do they will do everything they can
to dominate and Crush their opponents by
any means to maintain dominance because
they think if we're not in charge War
happens this is what gets me though the
liberal economic order the best thing
for that if they really want that to
succeed is to have an alliance with
Russia Russia is in the center of the
world essentially if you're looking at
China and the United States and Europe
and all that Russia is right there
whichever side Russia goes to is going
to gain a 90 60 more like they're gonna
gain so much power there's so much land
that's hard to travel that is like if
you have can put troops in Russia you're
good to go on a conflict so why would
they antagonize if the liberal so that
must be the GDP of Italy okay but they
also people need to understand the
context here if they shut off the oil
like it's not just about how much
they're charging it's about are they
even gonna give it to you at all but the
more oil we have on the market the
cheaper the oil is now deliberately
denying the oil makes the price of oil
go up even more than it automatically
would even if Russia was price hiking it
they would still have to compete with
other markets but right now the the
price of oil has gone up so much mainly
because of this this proxy war this
proxy conflict what gets me is I think
that people are manipulating the liberal
economic order to to go to war with
Russia to lose its power and and so that
they can be like well see it didn't work
out kind of thing and that there are
people in the liberal economic order
that are like they think they're doing
the right thing they think that they're
preserving democracy and and making
freedom but what's really happening is
they're antagonizing one of the
potentially greatest allies thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time